hi I'm Jessica Ford and I'm here to talk
to you about wireless router data so I'm
sure you all can remember the experience
of final season you you walk into the
library and you go to the place each of
the study at and you see someone has
already taken your spot so you think
okay well maybe i'll just try somewhere
else and that place is full and that
place is full and you end up spending
you know your whole day when you're
supposed to be studying actually just
looking for a place to sit so what it up
being able to say okay you know what
let's try to find out how cool these
studies faces are based on wireless
router data and create a tool about it
so myself and a bunch of students at
Columbia have created the website
density and let me share this with you
now see let me get the yeah we are this
is a density and density lists a number
of study spaces across campus and we're
actually able to see how full these
study spaces actually are we also have
some dining halls and the student center
and so this data is actually updated
every 15 minutes so it's a live feed
that helps people to get around campus
we also have a map functionality and
this actually shows us where on campus
peak places are full so for example this
part of the this part of campus is the
main library this actually shows how
full various floors on on butler library
are
so as I mentioned just get back this
clothing again so as I mentioned the
data is collected from client accounts
that are available from six libraries
one student center and the dining hall
and this is our anonymized counts that
are aggregated every 15 minutes we also
provide an API to the Columbia community
that allows people to access this data
and have the same ability to create
tools and understand student behavior or
campus behavior in general so actually
as part of the PI data we are sharing
this data with the PI data community so
this is the key you often use if you are
a member of Columbia you can just use
your Columbia email to get access to the
API and so I'm just going to show a
couple examples of the kinds of things
that we are sharing with the Columbia
community as I said data is supplied in
a 15-minute window so if you get the
latest route you can get the latest
information for all buildings if you
want to get a particular router we have
a group route that allows you to find
out how many people for example are on
the butler library 4th floor we also
collaborate this data up to the building
level so you can look across about
multiple floors and look at each floor
for the latest time stamp so for example
if you look to butler library we can
just click on this here and the JSON
with the latest data it will come up
serious
this is what it looks like as I
mentioned so you have our client count
which is the number of devices connected
to the router the time the ID of the
location the idea of the building and
our estimation for how full the space is
you we also have the ability to share
data within a time window this is also
available for both groups and buildings
and you can also just aggregate based on
this particular day both by building and
by floor so for example for this exhibit
this example we're looking at John Jay
which it has a bunch of dining halls on
october 10th from 8am to 930 p.m. and
again as i mentioned so these have now
you have multiple floors in this
building so we have John Jay dining hall
and JJ's place and we have the counts of
the routers and the number of devices
can I eat each router over time we we
paginator results so if you go to the
you're actually using this to gather
more extensive data we provide a next
page link so that you can just keep
reversing the results so if we were
trying to actually use this in Python
and do some analysis on this obviously
time day is very important to this data
so I'm just going to share some basic
functionality of pandas allows us to
work with this data so this is a basic
query for the dining for again the
dining hall building John J and this is
what it looks like when we pull it in
two pandas and then
we are able to then use the date-time
functionality daytime functionality from
pandas to be able to create the daytime
index and set that index to our data
frame for any of you who haven't used
this yet the daytime index allows us to
do some really basic filtering based on
your date month hour and so for this
I've just done a simple filter on a get
the results from 9am and so this is what
it looks like and then we actually can
also pull out different aspects of the
date times based on this index so we can
get the minute we could get what day of
the week it is we can get the hour and
also if we're not using furniture just
making this a series all right and we're
just putting this in the data you can
actually access this functionality with
the dot DT and I don't know you had DT
of the string you can actually access
all the same functionality in date times
for pandas so I'm going to share with
you some initial findings we found on
the data and we have a Jupiter notebook
that has everything including the actual
string for the key if you guys are all
interested in playing with the data so
I'm going to share that with you now so
again so this is this is a this is one
of our libraries at columbia and i'm
just going to loaded some libraries and
as i mentioned this is the this is the
authorization token that i'm sharing
with you all and this is the example
this is an example of the John Jay data
that i shared with you earlier um for
the sake of brevity i'm not going to
query the whole data set i'm just going
to take something we already have
pre-processed and I've already loaded it
and turn this into a date time so let's
see what this looks like oh that's it we
load this again
so while this is loading I'm actually
just going to go to our initial our
original results see so
are you see see
density PI data this is this data set is
pretty large I'm going to do that
okay so as I mentioned so this is the
this is a Jupiter notebook as I said
engine and this is this is the data we
shared earlier and this is actually what
it looks like on the server so we have
our time stamp we have the ID we have
the name we have the building ID the
name of the building and the number of
devices connected so this data set we're
playing with is a little over six
hundred thousand entries this is the
full list of buildings that we have
available so as I mentioned we we share
definitions of capacity and so how do
you actually do this so as you can
imagine college students to actually
crowd into spaces pretty easily but we
don't actually use that representation
of something like this where you know
people are having a party in the library
during finals to represent how full of
spaces because that's actually not
representative of typical usage we want
to be able to say you know a place like
this where people are sitting and
there's not that many spaces available
for you to sit down and study is
actually full so in order to do that we
consider what an average day looks like
so in this thing so in this example I'm
actually going to create a variable
called hrf rack which is basically just
a time of day that's created in decimal
points because we have is again the
minutes are on taking an interval so
it's a lot easier to work with if we do
fractions of an hour and then I'm going
to just create a plot that looks at this
time / day so we look over here this is
basically what the population growth of
devices looks at across Columbia across
all our locations so as you see there's
like a few people hanging out at
Columbia in the libraries early in the
morning most of the morning no one's
around and then it really begins to pick
up in the afternoon and then slowly
decreases into the evening interestingly
this is a little different from what we
see you would see in a office building
where people come in in the morning take
a break for lunch and then come back and
this is similar to see borns time series
plots we actually have some confidence
in
tools in here so you can see there's a
lot of variants going on so as I
mentioned cap capacity is a level which
population grows stabilizes on a given
day so if we if we want to look at that
then we would say okay you know what
what is the what is the value under
which this population curve growth
stabilizes so it would be somewhere
around here at around three o'clock say
right so then in this case will say okay
we are full at Columbia then add around
three o'clock and so whatever this arc
max value is is our capacity so in that
case you know at this in this plot we
would say at Columbia all our spaces are
full when there are about 244 2444 2443
44 devices connected at Columbia now as
I mentioned we have libraries we have
study space be of the student centers we
have various study spaces we also have
dining halls so dif different spaces
actually have different properties in
terms of people entering the building
and since everybody now has their phones
you can actually look at who's in the
building when and why all right so for
example this is a library this is butler
library but their library actually
behaves very differently from John J so
butler library as I mentioned you have
people coming people studying late at
night nobody's really around in the
morning people come in after after lunch
take a break for dinner and then they go
studying into the night interestingly as
I mentioned if you look at a job router
data from office buildings this will
actually be transposed three hours
earlier so everybody starts to coming in
around 9am they take a break for lunch
and then they work late into the night
this instead is actually John J so this
is I mention our dining hall so you see
there's actually some huge spikes
happening at around lunchtime and
dinnertime right then that totally makes
sense as I mentioned it's a dining hall
so how does campus population change
over time so if you actually look at
this this
population across campus at Columbia for
the whole year we can actually see when
people are off from school and when are
people not studying so if you see here
we actually have some really nice
technicality if you look in the summer
people aren't typically on campus and
then people so they start entering to
campus then we have a big dip around
Thanksgiving and then a big dip around
winter break then you see the same
powder again happen over winter break
and then people are coming back into the
spring semester but again you see
there's also within this time range some
some variation as well which indicates
that people aren't necessarily studying
equally every day of the week so in
order to better see this we're going to
try to group this weekly data in two
weeks so I'm actually so we index by
week of year and we're actually doing a
group by by the week of year and then
plotting this accordingly so given the
fact that we aren't starting we have
actually data across years we're doing
some manipulation around that to get the
indexes to match that we look around we
look over here this is the same plot now
with the data aggregated by week instead
of by day so again you see this is this
is Thanksgiving right that's your drop
of Thanksgiving this is your drop for
winter break this is your drop for
spring break and then this is what
happens in summer so again it's it's
there are some really interesting
cyclical properties in here so the
reason why we had to do this of course
is because the day of the week of fact
study habits so let's try to look at
this directly this is one my favorite
ones people going study on weekends so
everybody is around on campus on monday
tuesday wednesday thursday and then when
friday comes around nobody wants to be
on be in the library we can also find
some really interesting characteristics
of days with unusually high number of
devices so if we go through the days and
we say ok let's look for days that have
unusually high number of devices that
day and we're going to pick some days so
for example going to pick the auditorium
since that's one of our spaces and the
day with actually the highest amount of
device counts found
is in late summer in 2014 so let's look
at this what this looks like you see
here people are coming in for specific
periods of the day this is actually
again this is late summer so this is
around the time of orientation which
makes sense because you're bringing in
the new students and you're actually you
know giving them lectures and things
like that and then really interestingly
Columbia has a tradition called orgonite
where as I said people crowd into the
library and the band plays and you
actually can find it very easily in
butler library to which is here it's
where everybody shows up at the same
time and as I said even compared to
finals period there's many more people
in the library so they said you know
we've created some tools this is another
example of something else a student or
student Columbia made and so we have
this data and we would like to share
through the Columbia community we would
be happy to share this with you all
really curious to see what you all end
up using with for things that we would
like to do in the future as I said we've
even able to create these sorts of plots
we would love to be able to create some
dashboard functionality be able to allow
people to be able to better interact
with the data and see trends over time
I'm a machine learning person so
something I'm particularly excited about
is prediction and anomaly detection of
anas data set since you have some really
nice cyclical properties across the week
across the day across the month and so
this is an example of a the cover of
bays and data analysis the third edition
which is actually a daily data of births
from Andrew Gelman who's also who's at
Columbia and a bunch of other Beijing
statisticians and if you look here you
could actually see if you look very
carefully particular anomalous days of
the years that have unusually low birth
so for example New Year's Day has really
little births Independence Day Christmas
Thanksgiving labor day so we would
really like to be able to do something
like that if you want to look at our
website everything's open source this is
the link to the repo and thank you oh
yeah sure questions
so so I'm what we're what I'm hoping to
do is so that I've mentioned this paper
is a paper by akheeva taki and Andrew
Gelman and so what they're basically
you're doing is they're they're training
most of the multiple Gaussian processes
with different kernels and the kernels
are the kernels are relative to the
length of the window of different of
different periods so you have again that
represents the the variation that
happens on a weekly basis and then you
have one that represents the variation
that happens on a daily basis and from
there you can have a kernel that also
represents monthly variation if you look
you see here they have they have fit
Gaussian processes to tailor themselves
to each kind of cycle that's across the
month the year the time the weed day of
the week and so we can actually do a
similar thing by looking at actually
time of day because there is some really
nice cyclical properties that are very
predictable so that's kind of that's
generally the hope
I have to think about that one or that
i'm not quite sure
yeah I think I think in order I think
what we'd like to do is be able to
control for some of the variation that
happens within that time period itself
right because you go yeah you could you
could conceivably do that of course you
also doing something like this you would
be able to conceivably borrow across the
fact that you know that there are that
you have people in the same building so
you can also be able to hopefully
looking about look at in that way as
well I mean conceivably do doing
something within the same window would
be a lot more efficient but I think that
I mean it have to think about that I'm
hoping we the hope would be to be able
to look for particular events in time
like for example you know an orientation
or something like that no no we haven't
necessarily looked at that this as I
said this is very new data so we haven't
really done much analysis on it yes
so this is router data yes this is and
this is this has been provided by
Columbia's IT department so this has
been shared with us and we're sharing
this with the Columbia community
no this is the number of devices
connected to a router
no so in order to create at the level of
anonymization necessary to get to make
everyone happy we needed to aggregate it
on a pretty large scale so this is even
aggregated on the floor level so so even
you know obviously there more than one
router and a big floor but we've just
taken it all and put it in one bucket
so that's so yeah that's I think that
would be that would be predict pretty
hard to tell and you can use an estimate
and just I mean you could me a naively
another thing that we were considering
was naively just assuming that one
person is about three devices or
something like that or you know two or
three devices because you probably have
your laptop and you're probably of your
phone and maybe you'll have a tablet you
know so it's about two or three devices
and so you can get you can get pretty
close at guessing but without actually
coming it going in and you know doing a
census of how many people are in a space
it's really hard to tell okay thank you
you